let's talk about Bloom filters
not to be confused with the bloom shader effect
a bloom filter is a simple probabilistic
set originally conceived by Burton Bloom
yeah it's not some weird mathematical
Bloom it's just his last name
suppose you run a website where users post links
99% are cat pictures, cool new
websites, and YouTube videos
but every once in a while someone posts a link
to a known malicious site which you want to block
there's millions of known bad links so you pay for
a service that keeps a list
of them that you can query
calling out to the service costs money and
slows down your response times to your users
so you'd really like to know whether a
link is bad without querying the service
but with say 10 million bad links and
considering overhead it could easily
take a gig of extra RAM if you just
stored all the data in a Python set
with a bloom filter we could cut down on
98% of calls to the service using
only 10 megabytes of extra memory
but before we see how a bloom filter can help
your website first you're going to need a website
so please consider this video sponsor's
Hostinger for all your web hosting needs
Hostinger just happens to be running
their biggest ever Black Friday sale
where you can get their business
plan for as little as $3.49 a month
if you just want a tinker there's also the Premium
plan which goes as low as $1.99 a month and
comes with everything you need to get started
like a free domain, email, and SSL certificates
but if you want to run a site with some real
traffic I recommend the business plan which
additionally comes with increased
performance and access to Hostinger's CDN
when you check out make sure
to use coupon code MCODING to
get an additional 10% off on
top of the Black Friday deals
choose your free domain and use the
website builder if you're a novice
or deploy your site straight
from GitHub if you're a pro
and don't forget to use my custom link in the
description to let them know that I sent you
let's get back to bloom filters
a bloom filter is kind of like
a set in that you can add things
to it and it quickly tells you
whether an element is in the set
except when you ask if an element is in the set it
either tells you "possibly yes" or "definitely no"
in other words if it tells you "no"
the element is 100% not in the set
but if it tells you "yes" there's a
small chance the answer is actually "no"
oh yeah and you can't remove
elements from a bloom filter either
if you need to remove something you need
to create a whole new one from scratch
you're probably thinking this
sounds like a worse version of a set
why would I ever want a data structure that has
a restricted interface and
gives me incorrect results?
like many probabilistic data structures
the answer is that by giving up a bit in
accuracy and flexibility we can save
an enormous amount in performance
the catch is that you need a use
case where mistakenly identifying
an element as in the set when it's not is okay
that often occurs when you have a fast way to
compute something that works for most but not
all elements and a much more expensive way
to compute the same thing that always works
for our website we can use a
bloom filter to tell us yes
a link is possibly bad or definitely
no this link is not a known bad link
if the bloom filter says a link is possibly bad we
fall back to the paid service
to give us a reliable answer
so it's fine if we get a false
positive in a small percentage
of cases that's still a win compared to
sending everything to the paid service
great so how does a bloom filter work?
think about identifying objects by their shadows
shadows contain much less data than the originals
but given an object you can usually
tell whether it's part of a shadow
yes the shadows could conspire to trick you into
seeing something that isn't there but in
reasonable cases you can work around it
a bloom filter consists of a
block of memory that's M bits
long along with some number K of hash functions
in order to add an item to the
set we hash it using each hash
function and set the bit at the
corresponding memory location to 1
this pattern of bits from the hash
functions is like the object's shadow
then to query if an element is in the
set we look for its shadow by using each
hash function and checking whether
all the corresponding bits are set
if any bit is a 0 then this item
was definitely not added to the set
if every bit's a 1 it's either because
the element is actually in the set or
because some combination of other
elements happen to set those bits
so we can at best say the
element is possibly in the set
that's really all there is to the bloom filter
it uses a fixed amount of memory
no matter how many elements you add
and the time it takes to add or query
elements only depends on how many and
how slow your hash functions are not
how many elements were added already
its implementation is rather
simple we'll get to that later
all the difficulty lies in analyzing how much
memory and how many hash functions to use
if we use M bits of memory, K hash
functions, and added N items what's the
chance of falsely identifying an element
as in the set when actually it's not?
in real life it depends, measure it
but we can get a good approximate
answer if we assume the hash
functions select bits uniformly and
independently for distinct elements
for a fixed bit the chance that one
hash of a single element will set
that bit is 1/M so the chance that
the bit is not set is 1 minus that
for K independent hash functions to all not
set that bit we raise that to the power K
and repeating this for N total
elements we raise that to the power N
this is the chance that this fixed
bit is not set after adding N elements
therefore the chance this fixed bit is set
after adding N elements is 1 minus that
and a false positive means that K fixed bits
have all been set so we raise that to the power K
to finally arrive at our estimate
of the false positive rate
you can start plugging in numbers if you want or
using calculus we can approximate this as follows
multiply and divide by M
and then use the limit definition of e
and then rearrange
notice the quantity m/n is
something meaningful to us
that's how many bits of storage
we've allocated per element
if we fix that quantity to say
1 byte per element and plot
we see that we don't need a
huge number of hash functions
in fact the error rate is minimized
using around 5 hash functions
more generally, using calculus
take derivatives set to zero etc.,
you can show that we can achieve
an error rate as small as we like
by choosing the number of hash functions
to be about log base 2 of the desired
error rate and the number of bits per
element to be about 1.44 times that
so if we're okay with around a 2% false
positive rate then we could use five or
six hash functions and eight bits per element
for 10 million elements that's just 10 megabytes
of data regardless of how large each element is
because the filter doesn't
store the actual elements
okay but where can I get K different
hash functions for my data?
instead of inventing a bunch of hash
functions there are a few tricks you can do
like using a hash function that takes a seed or
appending k different suffixes
to your data before hashing
but here's a trick that can get the job
done using just one good hash function
if I'm using 10 megabytes of
memory that's 80 million bits
so my hash functions need to
output numbers up to 80 million
higher is fine we'll just mod by the length
but we need at least up to 80 million
log base 2 of 80 million is 26.25 so my
hashes really only need to be 27 bits long
how about I use a 256-bit hash and then just
split the first 240 bits into 5 chunks of 48 bits
treat each chunk as a separate
hash function and now I've got
five 48-bit hash functions that
I can use for my Bloom filter
obviously if you need many more hash functions
there won't be enough bits
and this trick won't work
but for our use case it does work
now let's implement it!
it's super simple this is the whole implementation
we take in the memory and a
function that computes the hashes
I chose to use a function that
outputs multiple hashes rather
than to store a list of hash functions
because hashes may share computation
like first computing the 256-bit
hash then splitting that into
5 48-bit chunks there's no need to
recompute the 256-bit hash five times
estimating the false positive rate is just
plugging into the formula
we had earlier in the video
adding an element means calculating each
hash and setting the corresponding bit to one
and checking if an element is in
the set means calculating each
hash and checking whether any of
the corresponding bits are not set
here we see how to split the output of a
hash function into smaller ones
which is pretty straightforward
the last "gotcha" we need to work around is that
in Python if we use a list of integers as
our underlying memory for the Bloom filter
that's going to be using 8 bytes per
index because under the hood python
will store a pointer to the unique cached
0 or 1 int object at each index location
that's 64 times more memory than the one
bit per index we assumed in our analysis
therefore to really make use of a Bloom filter we
should use something like a bit
array that uses one bit per index
we can Implement a bit array like this
have it hold the data which is made
of an array of bytes and a size
we keep track of the size separately because we
might want to store a number of bits
bits that's not a multiple of eight
so the array might be a few
bits longer than the size
we can construct an array of zeros like this
allocating a byte for every eight bits rounded up
getting a bit is just calculating which
byte and which bit within the byte using
divmod then grabbing that index
and masking out the bit we want
setting a bit is similar
this first expression we do a
bitwise "AND" to clear the bit
then the second one we do a bitwise
"OR" to set the value we want
putting it all together we can use it like this
we define a hash function in this case we just
use SHA256 and convert the result to an int
we split our long hash into five
hashes that use 6 bytes or 48 bits each
then we create our storage as a bit array
initialized to zeros and create the Bloom filter
I made a little timer utility here that
just times each operation, not important
we create 10 million random length-16
strings and add them to the Bloom filter
note that we're using a huge amount of memory here
because we continue to store the strings in memory
for the malicious link detection use
case we could add all the links to the
Bloom filter and then serialize just the
Bloom filter to distribute to our servers
the servers don't need to
keep all the individual links
so they would only need that extra 10
megabytes of memory for the bloom filter
not gigabytes for all the strings
just to check our implementation we
assert that there are no false negatives
meaning that everything that we did add
returns true when we check whether it's there
then we count false positives by querying an
equal number of strings that
were not added to the filter
and compare with the estimated false positive
rate based off our mathematical analysis
amazingly we find a 2.169% false positive rate
which is stunningly close to
the estimated 2.168% estimate
everything was completely random and yet we
predicted the answer with great precision
probability is pretty cool
anyway you probably noticed these times are
really long which is caused by the fact that
we're committing the cardinal
sin of doing a numerical hot
loop in Python for 10 million iterations
this won't really be an issue in
production since you're going to be
bottlenecked by waiting on the network
way before this makes any difference
but if you really want to I'm sure you could find
a decent C-extension that
implements a Bloom filter
my name is James Murphy
my company is mCoding and
we do software consulting
and once again thank you to
this video's sponsor Hostinger
don't forget to check out their current
sale and use coupon code MCODING at checkout
you can use my personalized
link in the description
also thanks to my patrons and
donors see you in the next one